the show is brought to you by the cash
up you know it it's the number one
finance app on the App Store all the
good podcasts say things like this you
know the cash app is the easiest way to
send money to your friends with the cash
app does more than that and you know
this
maeín cash app comes with the cash card
you've heard me talk about it's a free
debit card comes with boosts which are
like instant rewards for shopping at the
places you already love this is in case
people also want Theo von on my podcast
I'll just start talking in a southern
accent this is the regional and you can
get up to ten percent off your entire
purchase at door - and even save every
time you shop at Whole Foods Target and
more cash app is also the easiest way to
try and grow your money with the number
one investing feature unlike investing
tools that force you to buy and tire
shares of stock cash app lets you
instantly invest as little or as much as
you want that's called freedom this way
you can still own a piece of stock
freedom any stock purchase $1 brokerage
services are provided by cash app
investing a subsidiary of square and
member s I see I'm also excited to be
working the cash app to support what
charity The Trevor Project you already
speak souther thank you so mean to make
it worse if I'm not saying like this you
don't need to amp it up when you sign it
for the cash app use a promo code
Whitney do it please I'm shouldn't have
to say this again you're gonna instantly
receive ten dollars in cash that's gonna
donate ten dollars to The Trevor Project
your karma is handled it's an amazing
organization provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services to LGBTQ youth across America
we're also gonna do a giveaway
can you explain this giveaway basically
what you're gonna do is I need we're
gonna give away $15,000 toggle good for
you on this show we're giving y'all
$15,000 okay but what you need to do is
download the cash app we're gonna be
handing out tens twenties fifties
hundreds sometimes five hundred dollar
increments for you for free the cash app
is just gonna hook it up by yourself I
don't know Slanket what would you buy
with five hundred dollars Oh food
probably so
dad buy groceries okay great buy
yourself some garden that's what I need
okay how they gonna get this money um
God you and your freaking questions it
never ends with you oh you're gonna look
for the announcement post where you're
gonna have an opportunity to drop your
cash tag in the comments and then I'm
gonna give you money it's very simple
I'll just be me over and over you're
gonna be your hands yeah Fenton let's be
honest bet it's gonna be handling this I
can hardly read the copy download the
cash app from the app store right there
no you look good I have something in my
eye can you look it's a beard no that is
not your oh no that's my actual hair
fiber I sweated that out no you have
nothing in your eye I want to get like a
hook to put this yeah I have mine in my
way okay hey Lee Lee hello that's
beautiful
good voice yeah I really liked it I
don't I'm I'm also still of a cold so I
probably sound kind of nasally that's
the sexiest that's disgusting I don't
have like a sexy like like Katharine
Turner voice I just have like a
franchisor a voice she was sexy no I
know and um big news hot news hot big
news hot big news we're going on tour
we're coming to your city I'm going on
tour this is a tour announcement 25
cities actually a musical for you 25
cities 25 am I gonna survive this yeah
starting in March the how dare we call
it the how dare you tour of course which
is a great name you think yes how dare
you tour how dare you how dare I who do
I think I am of all people don't you hey
at home 25 cities leaving the kitchen
where I belong
in these field Nonna stop doing laundry
for once and go out and peddle my wares
25 cities and go into the tree he ste
Shiki Indianapolis sacré me this is
exciting
these are cities and everyone heard of
San Francisco Dallas Miami Chicago
Indianapolis Detroit Houston a lot of
cities Atlanta Cleveland Las Vegas
Nashville Nashville go to Nashville if
you don't ask for money to Anna pedal
tavern where Benton hails from yes we're
get you in a pedal tavern what you know
depends heaven ISM it's a it's a bar
that you pedal it's a you like it from
far away you don't live there those look
fun to me they are fine they're
definitely fine I think I'm gonna roll
my ankle alcoholism is alive and well in
the winter it's alive and well in my
genetics Huntington New York Montclair
New Jersey Clearwater Florida that's
near Tampa Bay what are Florida yeah
yeah yeah I feel like a crime happened
there sounds like it doesn't border no
don't do that don't have Floridians come
after us I like for I know the truth
we're going to we're going to Orlando
also but Clearwater I think or Tampa has
the or st. Petersburg has the Salvador
Dali Museum oh I love that I'm going to
that Salvador Dali's one of my favorite
artists yeah he's about I had a Salvador
Dali joke in my last special member oh
yeah and I cut it you did about your
boob yeah I was not comparing my boobs
to the melting clocks I know and when
people got it you really were happy I
know I was like you guys got that and
that was patronizing I ended up cutting
it Boston we're gonna Boston box and I'm
very excited about you're excited for
Boston I am excited for Boston why
because it's 45 minutes from Salem
Massachusetts there's the witch capital
of the world
yeah their high school is called
witchcraft hi why do you want to go
where a bunch of women were burned as
witches because I think that was where
the start of feminism happened witches
that's my theory that's what I believe
and I'm very touched a man with stones
but they weren't witches that's what you
think they accuse them of being witches
this is a hot take to agree with the men
that burned them listen first of all
most accusers are women oh really yes
and second of all haters I don't know
I'm sad to go I'm bringing up all these
cities because I want you guys to set
this is the first time that I'm touring
that I'm gonna really try to go to the
city the day before and do something
with the locals you know what I mean I'm
gonna do something in the city to
appreciate the city cuz normally I fly
in I've landed up five I have to rush to
the menu I go on and I fly out at 6 a.m.
the next morning and I don't get to like
appreciate the city I wonder you're
gonna try and join something that's what
I'm gonna be a tourist so I want you
guys to send me things to do and all
these cities ideas like places to hike
museums I should go see local diners I
should patronize so you guys I think the
best way to do it easy there DM Benton
lol just flood him with your ideas so
that he could see you know me so well
that yeah yeah yeah because I'll find
the quiet place yeah and you'll like
filter out all the like don't send me
zoos you know I don't like zoos
sanctuaries that are legitimate and
accredited not like bullshit fake
sanctuaries where you're like swimming
with Tigers and inbred animals yes
that's not humane you know me I won't
like it and you can text me at the it's
on my Instagram but it's 8 1 8 to 3 9 7
5 to 7 let's talk about the texting
really quick really quick you love it I
do love you do this thing you can text
me directly I can read your texts for
those of you just listening you can't
see me doing this I'm holding this up on
YouTube I'm getting your texts I'm going
through them most of you guys are very
grateful you're excited you can text me
but some of you are losing your goddamn
minds are in a paranoid spiral and you
think I'm like stealing your data I'm
not people are really worried some
people DM me being like why has one
you're not text me back hi texture can
you tart attack I'm trying I'm doing the
best I can
habit this is the best I can do I'm
getting thousands of texts I'm just I am
responding to so many of them and if I
if I take a swig of mic well it's your
lucky day because I have been engaging
with people giving them life advice
giving them veterinarian medical advice
you're wild I'm not I'm responding to a
couple people really thoroughly to the
point of where I just I feel like this
is gonna end up in a restraining order
mine or them unclear but the texting
thing the idea is that when I go on tour
you can text me places to go I can text
you I'm coming to Atlanta here's some
free tickets the first couple people to
text me back you benefit from this I get
nothing out of it and it's more direct
than like a DM which is kind of lost dmg
lost but also I think with marketing now
I don't want to fill up my Instagram
grid with just promoting my shows it's
annoying
it isn't it's gross and plus the
algorithm like you have to like people
have to like another tour to even see a
tour post that goes no lauren hill's the
Hollywood Bowl and I didn't even know
about it yeah I'm mad about it to you
I'm like her biggest fan I didn't even
hear about it so marketing I think
there's so much clutter now that just
posting on Instagram is not enough like
oh is my biggest pet peeve when I go to
freakin st. Houston and I do five nights
of shows in Houston then I go to the
airport and so I'm sick oh my god
Whitney I'm such a big fan what are you
doing in Houston and I'm like bitch I
just did five nights of shows how did
you do you follow me
yes do you follow me on Twitter yes you
follow me in Instagram yes so how did
you not see this you say bitch I just
did bitch I've been here for five days
Houston so this is a way I can get
directly to you if you don't want to
text me and don't want to get text from
me don't don't then go can I get off
this list get an unsubscribe me from
this list the fuck out of here
ungrateful y'all are in grace not all of
you just some of you just the ones I'm
talking about you saw me this morning
everything a birthday video every
morning I wake up I make a special vert
birthday video specifically for everyone
whose birthday it is look at this look
at this you saw me I was singing I was
dancing listen to this
[Music]
no make it stop that's why they want to
unsubscribe that was a special birthday
video I made this morning for everyone
whose birth every morning I make a
special video and then some people were
back can you take me off this I don't
want them stealing my data like I just
put a lot of effort into that that's one
attention yeah maybe that's true I just
want you to be like no please don't
leave so they're sending you diems
telling me to respond they're sending
mediums there in your DMS which is a
whole different mess of a story all I
want is just if you guys send me
pictures of your dogs send me pictures
of your animals your cats your horses
and your dicks Thanks
no no more dicks your dick pic this
situation on your dam is you have
created is insane it's insanity like it
is too many dick pic it's too much
confidence I love it and you have like
weird categories of guys who want to
send you dick pics like you have a call
these twinks and you dick pic does it
swing like I read aloud to say that
what's twink I said you can say whatever
you want okay alright I'm not gonna
silence you give all these between you
know like little like little boy it's
like warped or dudes are they of age
yeah we hope you know their crime going
on in my dams I know about like a lot of
twinks not to be confused with Tinker
Bell which are very different excuse me
your twinks gonna be peed on that's
whatever addiction is that real and then
you have like these old men who are very
confident and they want to send you like
pictures of their dick with like with
these like a Thor tative stances like
you know what you need to milk this dick
and raised like what
sir go drink your stew get out of here
the old men dicks I don't mind it I'm
have a hot take on the dick pics I don't
I think they're funny I find them
entertaining
I'm not upset they don't traumatize me
personally because I just I think it's
an I just I love I talked about this on
the h3h3 podcast like I love seeing
people's decor in their home and if it
means I have to see a dick to the
foreground I'm fine with that so what
you're getting no I'm getting grown man
full body hair and then a shaved crotch
I could just a crops over around there
dick that's not normal
it's grow one boy just sent you a
picture of him fully nude in the mirror
and there was a cup of shrimp ramen find
his dick I love me ramen you know I
order in bulk that's insane
like who are you trying to appeal to
was it me it's working what do you dip
his dick in there shrimp flavor like
that's weird
did it was it finished there was a fork
and I couldn't see inside there but it
was mean I just I love the story behind
that I'd love that he's like I'm gonna
eat my ramen cuz you gotta wait for the
noodles to get soft and the dick to get
hard that's perfect and you know who
wants to see that weird new comment like
I'd I love you know what I love the most
this is such a weird fetish I love
looking at people's bathrooms I love
looking at the products in their shower
I love looking at the the sliver of
Irish Spring soap the I love Xena the
little the salon selective's two and one
I like seeing the Prell I like seeing
what people buy I just my favorite thing
is looking at people's towels because
I'm fast I'm fascinated by people that
have colored towels so crazy to me I see
people got red towels like they're
Rajneesh cult leader or they have yellow
towels they're just shitting in a field
of sunflowers stop yellow yellow and
purple I'm like are you a Laker like
what's happening
no there's all cut people are all over
it is a Lakers beat staff you know I'm
telling you people are all over the
place with it like Tao hand towels with
patterns on them I get it for your
bathroom cute little pigs little puppy
whatever cars I once caught Jay Leno
some hand towels that had little cars on
them do a lot of men that send you dick
pics
yes have pattern I've seen the bars of
soap the little that's gross no I showed
you that guy that had a yellow towel the
other day shaved we should put this in
I'll send this to you guys there was a
guy ah look at this yellow towel this is
a giant dick with a bright yellow towel
in the background yes that's how he
appears sorry we probably can't show
this on camera I'll show it to you guys
I love seeing guys color to their towels
keep sending me dick pics just because
I'm not embarrassing are you an
embarrassed by his lack of pubic hair I
think it's funny that is embarrassing
but it's a grown man I'm sure my
producers dick pigs I feel like time's
up on me it's gonna get me in trouble
alright well I think everyone's really
just listening to this cuz they know
bilborough's on the show and they're
scrolling good reason they want to hear
a bill burr he's not here yet
so I thought that I would just really
quick talk to you about the fact that I
think someone needs to do an
intervention on me in the nyquil oh it's
too much Betty Ford has this is waiting
for me to come down there and detox the
nyquil is I can't believe this shit's
legal it's too good you you don't have
the personality no hmm I should not let
nyquil the fact that this shit you can
just buy at the store is why it's made
to rest and you're taking it with the
intention to work well no what do you
sleep at some point no I just I take it
and I give myself this arbitrary amount
of time I'm like I'll take it and then
like in 30 minutes I'll go to bed I'll
wait for it to kick in but night that's
what like edibles takes like 45 minutes
alcohol sometimes nyquil hits you like
hard wall and I have been really
paranoid about this coyote problem in my
yard I've had like five coyotes every
night between like 2:00 and 4:00 a.m. I
look at my ring camera every morning and
I see them prowling the prowl and the
prowling they're trying to eat my dogs
they're trying to eat my family I don't
like it some primal squeals telling it's
starting to kick up no during the day
right now I'm just on caffeine right now
and some lithium you know I take lithium
everything so I'm and some juice some
berries and I'm paranoid and when I get
paranoid and take sleep aids I do crazy
shit at night so I started checking my
ring camera the other day and much to my
surprise and chagrin I discovered myself
sleepwalking sleepwalking can you guys
pull this thing up I'm sleepwalking at
5:00 in the morning I thought I was
gonna see coyotes Oh God it's me hold on
turn it up because I walk out yelling or
I'm like making a little noise walk out
you go better bet is that hey are you
gonna what's your project is you're
trying to scare them away I thought
they'd be out there so I just walked out
and went like I don't know I don't want
no recollection of this I'm not
conscious hey yo D you want to get back
baby back you want to fight me in my
dogs you want to get bit no recollection
that's my favorite part somebody needs
to take the nyquil from me you're a
nine-hole brain dead set there's a
coating who knows what else I did not on
camera
buried something over there and then I
checked the next night the next night I
came home from doing stand-up had a
little shot of nyquil like a lady came
out don't remember this started peeing
where the Coyotes normally are in a full
blazer full businesswomen piss like
right off work I'm coming home to sign
some papers piss in my own yard
you almost peed on your dog and you're
on your phone while you're peeing I'm
standing up being now I think I got it
on my shoe I don't remember this I have
no recollection of this whatsoever and
it's starting to one hand on the ground
like you're twister doing you you're
trying to keep balance because you're
off your ass on night well anyway this
is probably not something for audio
because you guys don't know I'm saying
this is a YouTube exclusive is that such
a thing this is only for YouTube you
subscribers alright I feel like I've
embarrassed myself what did I just do
you scream are you walking outside a bit
that is the funny thing for her my life
is so embarrassing a pajama set and
socks I'm really alarmed by the things
that I do and I quote so I need you to
take it away from me you can't let me
use this shit anymore
I hope you enter every room like that
from now on I'm gonna start trying to
make these podcasts not so long we're
having too much fun and we need to keep
them tight every episode with two and a
half hours long that's what people
always one short or fun yeah the last
fun bill bursts here and we are blessed
and highly favored Wesson highly favored
25 city tour blessed and highly favored
Albers here
did you see the complaints about the
Irishmen I didn't want to ask you about
it I haven't zero complaints I just wish
it was another two and a half hours
longer someone had the audacity to
complain that Anna Paquin didn't have
enough lines who said fix someone on
some blogger like Anna Paquin didn't
speak enough in the movie that's so
stupid it's like well it wasn't about
her Jimmy Hoffa you know say less so
this blogger can get in there yeah
that's not the story you don't get to
complain about Martin Scorsese the
number of lines people have oh you
actually you do you do and then
everybody picks up on it because
somebody's complaining and it looks like
it could be a controversy so then they
did they blow it into a brush fire and
they just they just keep gassing up
things that I guess people care in that
they like watching people argue and
debate and some people getting in
trouble but as far as people like that's
what people truly care about I don't
think it is it's like rubber necking or
something but it's also like okay
Charlie's Angels didn't do well book
smart which is directed by a woman and
starring women didn't do it was a good
movie no one saw it so if the people
that were complaining about it would
just go see the movies that wouldn't it
was vegan maybe they would actually
probably a bit about that where they
bitch about women in the NFL it's like
what about the WNBA where there's like
30 people at every fucking game why
don't you go support that you don't
actually wanna buy tickets you just want
to complain that other people are buying
tickets yeah or that yeah we should guys
ya know it's insane it's an it's a very
but I think it's died I think it it's
just it's did died of its own weight I
mean I even saw like a lot of you know
the people champion the flag even
they're trying to distance themselves
that fucking happens when you get old
like me you see that happen so many
times these trends and people just jump
on them and they'll riding that horse
and they're at the front carrying the
flag then all of a sudden they see the
cliff coming I wasn't a part of it
what's up with those guys uh they're
rollerblading what's that you know I
always use rollerblading isn't it as an
example that everybody did it and then
is that one homophobic joke and then
everybody
acted like they never did it so zilean
um I loved rollerblading I played
rollerblade hockey I had a great fucking
time I would do it again fun I would do
it again if I wasn't so old
because what killed rollerblading for me
was the the protection that they had was
so fucking uncomfortable in door key
well if you wore like the kneepads right
it would just make the back of your leg
sweat profusely what would make me fall
yeah you can't actually get anything
going I used to do it when I lived in
Philadelphia I would rollerblade
everyday I'm seeing it you're acting it
painting a picture I can see what's
happening here
first I just want to say a couple I like
to plug up fronts you know I mean plug
up front people like to bury the plugs
at the very end when people I do that
stupid you know f is for family it's on
season four I love it so much oh thank
you and I have a question about when you
when you were animating what were the
conversations about what's the skin look
like what are the features look like
thank you
that takes weeks you spent like that we
spent like weeks on noses and chin eyes
well what you have to do is you have to
see what's out there and then you have
to come up with something different you
literally have to create your own race
of animated people it's like all right
the Simpsons are yellow yeah
South Park is doing the minimal thing
and you know all that stuff on you know
we looked at a lot of stuff on what's
this a Robot Chicken and the show
ayisha's on there the Spice oh I've only
watched a zillion episodes of it I got
my brain it's the worst you know you
know can someone pull it up that's why
we have a monitor
I leave that animated show you Tyler's
everyone's running around panicking huh
all right Archer everyone's panicking
cuz you're here I've never seen people
move around so much while we're
recording everyone's just moving around
yeah my shit moving yeah so we just we
just like looked at a zillion things
like that and we tried to come up you
know and it was all trying to get Frank
Frank was this sort of the centerpiece
it's like we couldn't make him to hang
he had to look like he is somebody
trying you know because the way I was
going to
in yelling and stuffy we wouldn't come
off as like too sympathetic so yeah it
started with that but you know speaking
of The Simpsons you know Mike price yeah
co-creator and so he's guided us through
pretty much all the Whitewater of the
first three seasons Peter Billingsley
Vince Vaughn all of those guys
Victoria Vaughn all of those people over
at Wild West so you know surrounded
myself with people who knew what the
hell they were doing it's also like
watching animation it's just so soothing
for me now cuz everything is I hate the
word triggering but you watch any show
now and you're like didn't he have an
allegation or got out of my lap like
it's just like everything's so floated
now so what you do is you just don't
watch the news really social media news
that's right and you can enjoy Bill
Cosby's entire back catalog I'm kidding
I mean but I mean you know you don't get
into every fucking thing that's going I
tapped out of politics I have to I
tapped on it what's going on where but
you did then once you push through that
then you have to then I think try to do
something in your world that helps
somebody out right like you know help
you won or whatever if you can homeless
people public schools or something that
you can pick up on so I I'm against just
saying well you know politics are crazy
you know it does make a difference what
color tie they're wearing baba wawa it's
like fine I agree with all of that but
like after that then so what you what
are you just not gonna do anything and
just act out for yourself
no that's kind of what they're doing I I
realized that I was kind of doing that
so but I definitely do a lot of me TVs
another big one for me yeah me TV I just
watch memorable entertainment television
don't even know what it is you should
know what it is you're still young and
have your life ahead of you it's all the
shows that I watched when I was a kid
some of which that were already 10 and
20 years old
it's like Rockford Files yeah Jack
Gunsmoke you know Peter Gunn 77 Sunset
Strip yeah Hillbillies Buck Rogers
cannons a great one the original
Charlie's Angels alum Bo Columbo is a
great one
from strokes the artist a show if I
could find one that was on I would watch
that gilligan's and the problem is now
people want to go up and tear these
apart that's a traditional gender role
that's implies well they should only be
in people don't a select few group of
people like 30 bloggers 30 bloggers can
can move the needle and so Mannix is a
great when I said Maddox Mannix Matlock
I love Matlock or I got now look who's
great all of those things she wrote on
Isla raha diverse TV role so I just sit
there and I watch that and there's like
there's no global warming the promised
Wonder Woman never did much for me
because I always felt like Wonder Woman
did less than the average just woman
yeah but she was hot she's buying her
drinks you know I remember really good
Wonder Woman and being like my single
mom is doing more than you just did in
that episode well she got her pilot's
license she's instrument-rated up there
in the clouds you gotta give her that
that's a big move for a chick back in
the 70s you have your helicopter pilot's
license I hear yes I do does that not
scare you uh yeah it's terrifying
but it's something that once you get
past that the fear it's fucking
incredible and it's an unbelievable
privilege or whatever but like I you
know I'm very careful with it so right
up here is where the LAFD lands to
refill water when they're putting fires
out and I go up there and watch them and
it brings tears to my eyes to watch
these guys I can't fly only got a couple
hundred hours I I don't know what I'm
doing but those guys are fucking amazing
so it's a hobby yeah let's talk about
paper tiger it's out I'm sure you've
already seen it especially if you're
listening to this show
Jessica curse on your producing her
special December 6 that comes out she's
hilarious yeah she's one of those I was
saying like this some comics you know
that you really have to have a game plan
after they go on and she's one of them
where it's just like hey I was gonna try
some new shit I think I gotta go play
with the crowd a little bit and try to
make them try to forget her but she's
just she's the real deal and she
didn't skip any steps oh and she went
all the way around the track yeah
went all the way around the track so
she's ready to go so we're expecting big
things out of that and you know the
specials that we've done you know we did
one with Paul virzi and we did one with
the in Edwards and and now Jessica and
Paul virzi is now selling out comedy
clubs which is so great
I do miss working with him on the road
but I I do and I'm obviously super happy
for him that you know just seeing
somebody make it like that is awesome
and plus I love Paul I always said Paul
I want to see you get money just because
I want to see what you're gonna buy no
you're gonna buy like an alligator
something like you know what I'm a no no
no it's it's yeah yes I love that you
did this I mean you produce my special
these guys were it was such a different
experience like I don't think people
understand that most comedians they work
their asses off they get ready to shoot
special and then everyone person they're
special like is a lawyer or like a trust
fund kid or they rip you off or they I
have been stolen from so much lied to oh
yeah someone cause there's some
characters out there and they take
advantage of comedians because comedians
for me I'm just so happy to be there and
I didn't know shit about production I
didn't know where people were stealing I
got screwed on my earlier ones as far as
like budgetary stuff and then when I
found out what was going on I was just
like oh these people are finding out
what my budget is and then budgeting it
to like within a nickel that's right and
I don't think how they find out or they
give people kickbacks for letting let me
know and I'll throw you five grand if
you find out what his budget is am a
little fuckin you know and they just
just stuff like that it's really super
super shady I knew another guy who was
driving people you know towards a
failing streaming channel because yeah
he was getting like 50 grand a pop C so
yeah to drive him oh yeah yeah and even
so he had a sigh everybody's got a
fucking side deal this is deal it is
what it is so we wanted to create a
business where you know like a place
where comics could go on their podcast
yeah they could come have a vision for a
special we try to
make it happen and you know we don't
have that you know we own everything
that you do I mean we still have to make
our money but like we're not doing that
yeah you know old school record deal
kind of shit that they do around here
I'd say just follow all things comedy
their Instagram and just watch whatever
comic cuz it's bill and al Madrigal
picked them and they're gonna be good
you're gonna be at I always loved this
because you're gonna be just for Laughs
in Montreal I mean it's probably already
sold on yeah
in February you're going to Vancouver oh
I was just four laps to me is in July in
Montreal yeah that's right no this is
Vancouver they oh the Vancouver one in
February I always loved these comedy
festivals because you find out your
value in the business based on how big
your name is on the flyer I know how
about you always find out because
there's always a list of comedians and
names and what row you're on a happy
trip then you're gonna see somebody else
so I'd be doing it long as their name
bigger on this fuckin poster actually
Vancouver there's a guy I know up there
that flies helicopters and last time I
went up there I got to fly one
unfortunately it was like an overcast
day so I didn't get to quite see the
incredible beauty up there so I'm gonna
try to thank you I think is the most
gorgeous place on the plane yeah it's
expensive his shit yeah everyone
everyone of all the people I've had on
so far which have not been a lot
everyone was the most worried about this
appearance every was like he's not gonna
like your chairs he's not gonna like the
worst fucking like reputation everybody
he's gonna be angry he's gonna be all of
that I don't know maybe that's survived
I'm putting up like cross my arms and
get all closed up no I think I think
people assume I get this to where people
look why are you so angry and I'm like
dude you're seeing me on stage where I'm
letting out all my anger that's where I
let it out it was funny you've never
come across as angry to me really on
stage we don't think no I just thought
it was funny I didn't think it was like
but I mean it's also be saying I don't
think that's angry I know you're not
like a Yeller really when you're honest
I haven't seen you know I don't think I
complain a lot people are like you're so
you complain a lot and like that's weird
it's comedy I mean what's just what I'm
doing like I'm not do do people really
think that or did a couple of people say
that you that that bored people is
really thrown well see I love that you
say that people are saying I can't stay
at studio two comments alone when
everyone is like on their instagraming
like you know a lot of people want me to
post my skincare routine I'm like you
want to do it there just took one person
and you're pretending everyone wants it
but no I think in general like I've
gotten that feedback over the years and
maybe I'm sensitive to it because I do
know that I have anger problems but I
actually don't think I you know you only
sort of respond to criticism if you
deeply in some way kind of agree with it
that's the only time it bothers me
I don't think oh I think someone can
just say something really mean and
hurtful you think that about yourself
yeah fuchal is it
this is human beings are way too complex
for like just one one thing like that
and my wife tried some shit on that I
said something and then she seats some
stupid fucking expression pet dog bites
or something I don't know what the fuck
it meant it was just this way of going
like oh cuz you reacted to the fucked up
thing that I said it's on you it's like
that up still on you
we had a funniest fucking argument the
other day we were watching Wheel of
Fortune in the fucking prize was because
they the worst prize ever was it was
like a fucking shopping spree at Dick's
Sporting Goods you get that on a game
show you win that out of calling in a
radio station these people are on TV
solving puzzles and then she said you
know she was you know I wouldn't care if
I was on I just give that to you now
when you what fuck you fucking dehghan
gonna dicks myself are you fuckin gift
certificate antigen I get so fucking I
can just in a silly way that she would
just be like imagine if I ever did that
you're with your Keeping Up with the
Kardashians horse shit I get a fucking I
get Dick's Sporting Goods I just got in
a fight there's a hoodie next to a
fishing rod some bear spray there's the
Nike shit that didn't work so it's not
at our flagship stores there's some um
bro shorts yeah some a regular adidas
socks I was just fighting with benched
about this because we're talking about
holiday gifts and I'd
like gift cards you don't like don't
like them like be like don't get me
anything literally just don't get me
anything that's how much I don't like
gift cards because I always end up going
to the place you got me the gift card
for spending more than it and then it
ends up costing me money oh I was
thinking just getting cash cash cash is
a great what you do that is such an
underrated gift cash $100 cash I like
you I don't know much about you seems
like this will cover it we could be
friends for another year 20 40 60 get
the fuck out of here where it feels
dirty but it's all anyone actually wants
I don't like gift cards what do you do
what are you gonna have you already
decided we're gonna get your wife for
that holiday we can't say Christmas I
got Christmas actually Christian I
actually celebrate Christmas I'm sorry I
was in a writer's working on a show not
practicing Christian enough and an
intern complained because I said Merry
Christmas I know it's it's so batshit
crazy out there where it's just like
like the shit that people who haven't
done anything with their fucking lives
are calling out these I just remember
coming in when you were in the mail room
was just like yes sir no sir how are you
not saying that was right but now this
thing where the person who built the
Empire has to crumple to their knees
because someone in the fucking mailroom
didn't like the mistletoe it has seven
followers on Twitter yeah and then they
can literally ride that to like the ABC
morning show I'm sorry
tell China put China on hold for that
big billion dollar deal I need to I need
to put this fire out it's it's like but
it's also been fun to watch in that all
of these so-called like powerless people
when they complain is then you then
watch them abuse that power yep like the
company or the exact same fucking thing
you're just not up there and everyone's
saying that's like that whole horse shit
where they show like you know inner-city
kids and every one of them was who's
dealing drugs would have been a doctor
yeah yeah if they grew up in a white
neighborhood it's just like yeah or they
could have been like some of my piece of
shit fucking white people that I know
they could have been they could have
done a predatory Bank and fucked old
people out of their pensions it's not
you don't automatically become a fucking
hit like it's one of those just
romanticize anybody who's in the mail
room is this fucking Saint
and anybody who's up top is autumn and
it's just that's not the case there's
some good people in mail room yeah and
there's some absolute pieces of shit and
same thing with people who run companies
that's that that's what I think dealers
would be doctors holiday rush she's
coming you need shipstation if you sell
stuff online you better get ready with
chip station and with more people buying
more than ever online before I said that
out of order you have to be able to ship
orders out quickly duh efficiently duh
and affordably but how do you keep track
of all those orders I couldn't do it or
how do you decide what shipping carrier
to use it's a nightmare or how do you
know if you're getting the best rapes
bop bop bop luckily shipstation
can help they sort this all out just a
few clicks you'll be managing orders
printing labels getting those products
out the door and deliver for the
holidays bam bam what no problem okay if
you're selling on Amazon Etsy your own
website shipstation brings all the
orders into one thing interface making
it easy to manage all that blessed and
highly favored less than highly favorite
stuff even you can do from your cell
phone ship station works with all the
major carriers UPS FedEx UPS any enough
to deal with any nonsense there you can
compare you can choose you can ship come
on it's the number one choice of online
seller so what are you doing where you
can go to the number two choice what do
you maniac you know I want to compare
and choose what are you kind of
psychopaths take the hassle out of
holiday shipping let shipstation help
you handle it all with ease use my offer
code Whitney to get a 60 day free trial
don't use anyone elses offer code don't
screw me on this you're going to get two
months free of no hassle stress free
holiday shipping
but just visit shipstation dot-com click
on the microphone at the top of the page
type in Witney if you don't know how to
spell it can't help you
shipstation calm enter offer code
Whitney ship station make shit happen
hello fresh with hellofresh
America's number one milk it you can
easy seasonal recipes and pre measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
cooking delicious meals at home a
reality regardless of your comfort level
in the kitchen from step-by-step recipes
to pre measured ingredients you'll have
everything you need to get a WoW worthy
dinner on the table in about how many
minutes about 30 minutes
say goodbye to endless grocery store
trips and takeout food hellofresh has
you covered
make deliciousness a part of your week
Benton break out of your dinner rut
you're always in a rut I me my dinner
right yeah hello fresh has how many
seasonable chef curated recipes a 20
plus there's stuff more than 20 that's
more than heard of you from family
recipes to calories smart vegetarian fun
menus like what Hall of Fame craft
burgers hellofresh is more you caught me
on the calories I really I'm here for
that you really blanked out hella fresh
has more five-star recipes than any
other meal kit holy moly soon they're
gonna get something fresh is the only
meal could I know about yeah well I mean
I'll it's for many reasons yeah 9 free
meals with hellofresh you're gonna go to
where hello fresh com / good 9 and use
code good nah that's how many free meals
no with hello fresh by going to hello
fresh coms / good 9 and use the code
good night
I also didn't hire someone is this crazy
that you sang it on mic yes and if they
figure it out and then they sue you so
fucking much at this point I was
interviewing someone and I was like so
what kind of comedy do you like and he
went I like so-and-so I really like
their stick and that felt like a red
flag stick is that weird
this made might be an old soul ID I mean
that would have kind of made me laugh
stick I like this little borscht belt
hey kid what's your act stick and it's
someone I knew and I was like that's a
great comic they don't have a stick
they've an act to like I don't get how
an assistant makes your life easier I
agree
I haven't hired one Karen all of those
people are gonna talk who we're gonna
talk to you are gonna talk to them and
then you have to talk to that person and
then they regurgitate it back to you
okay so you still had the conversations
and then you are one person removed from
your career now yeah there's this buffer
yeah and what if you hire a fucking
lunatic yes I've done that yeah I think
have you hired anyone who's slowly
trying to become you yes single white
female and it's also I end up hiring a
lot of people that like a couple months
in or like I have to go to my improv
class or like I have to go like I got a
spot at the Comedy Store and I'm just
like alright fine but I don't know I
like um I always liked helping people
like I want it cuz no one gave me really
any of that I didn't really get to work
for other people and learn from other
people so I don't know I kind of like to
I like to do that I heard Benton he was
opening for me on the road and then I
found out he was dyslexic I kept missing
meetings and then I keep him around I
don't even care these days like I
figured I'd keep it like you know you
like - I just do all my shit yeah and if
I get if I don't go as far I don't I'm
okay with that I just can't answer
emails I get I get enraged when one
email turns into five emails I just I
get him raged cuz I feel like people are
stealing my time and I I get I get irate
know what I'm starting to see that anger
light up certain things make me very
angry and uh like I think it started
since my dad died I get angry when
someone takes up too much of my time or
like wasting my time or when anyone is
abusive to a child or an animal in
public I use it so before your dad died
you didn't care if somebody beat the
shit out of their kids with a puppy I
think I wasn't as conscious of the
consequence of confronting them about it
like I wouldn't confront him about it I
was like that sucks that pisses me off
now I confront people no tell me what
you think of this I saw a woman in a
grocery store and she had a flake a
five-year-old kid and the kid kept
taking the Lucky Charms and putting it
into the shopping cart and the woman
would take it out and put it back in the
kid would take it and put it back and
the woman start getting pissed and she
was like put it back in see what happens
put it in see what happens and I was
just like that's sarcasm it's clear the
kid didn't know it was sarcasm and the
kid was like didn't understand if it was
an order but kind of knew something was
up was this kid what was this bill was
he husky that's mothering I know that
that is what you're seeing is three
seconds of being a mom and she's dealt
with NAPA little fucking brat yeah you
know like yeah this like I think there
was cellphone cameras around when I was
a kid this shit that all the moms were
doing yeah my mom used to grab my ear in
public and drag me out of a grocery
store my mother one time threatened that
if my two younger brothers didn't knock
it up she was gonna spank their bare
asses on the side of the road and she
fucking did it
and people drove by keeping the horns
laughing yeah whatever it's a different
time I mean there was this shit that
needed to be improved upon and then but
I think a lot of that old school kind of
parenting is coming back a little bit
you know there's always like you know
going too far this way then we over
correct that way or whatever you know do
you find yourself I I'm terrified of
having kids mostly because I'm terrified
of having to be friends with parents
that I don't like have you found
yourself yet having to like be on like
playdates um no I that I I mean if I
don't like a group set of parents and I
book that that's it it's one and done
so but what if they become friends who
becomes your kid and their kid um my
kids not old enough where that's
happened okay so it's just been a my
parents all the parents have been cool
there's just I just don't like those
people always forecasting doom yeah so
they'll be like how old you kid and I'll
be like oh she's seeing out two and a
half Oh terrible twos terrible twos and
I'm like nah nah she's actually really
cool I'll wait three three n'ajjer three
and it's just like it's like maybe you
suck as a parent yeah whole kid like why
because you fucking this is like nothing
people some who sucks at their job and I
gotta sit here and listen to you yeah
forecasting my kid is like the happiest
fucking resting my kids ever you don't
know him yeah she's just like I have a
great relationship with her and if I
start to flip out she literally says dad
dad no don't no no no screaming that'd
be right you're right but I like because
she's not if she's not afraid of me she
respects me but she's not afraid of me
it's kind of like you know doing
something I'm doing good so far can I
ask you an intimate question you can
pass did you have runner-up names like I
don't remember I'm fascinated by names
cuz now it's like it's um I was going
through with a friend of mine and
everyone starts to name their kid the
same names you know like Olivia Jack
James like there's a sigh just gets so
fascinated when people Jack and Olivia
beautiful names know they love those
those would be Mike but there was that
weird time where everybody was trying to
act like their kid was a cowboy and
another was a lot of that sort of state
none of us want to go shoot we all look
down on here in LA and people like LA
rich snobs were naming their kid Montana
yeah they would never go there yeah
lettering bought a bunch of land out
they wanted to do it I don't know what
it was but like yeah there was
definitely some yeah it you know I get
fascinated by like the trends of names
you know
some of them go away that need to go
away there's a few names that I've seen
out there it's like you yeah you gonna
homeschool that kid if kids are as mean
as I remember growing up it's just like
I don't understand why you would do that
but you know what it's their kid yeah
they can name it what if they want I've
no sympathy my last name is Cummings I
got it pretty hard you know it's funny I
never even thought about that
you've always been Whitney Cummings yeah
so I never thought I never put sometimes
you just have two separate name for me
to see it to see how bad it is and you
know like there was guys I grew up with
like you know I would watch playing
sports and their name was their whole
name and then one day someone just say
their first thing I was like oh my god
that's a fucking terrible name yeah I I
would get like I'd get the worst shit
when I would get my papers back like in
high school people will have scratched
it out and turned it into like cum shot
like come on your face like it was just
constantly and you like someday I'm
gonna get married at 18 get rid of this
fucking last III also this no one
believes this but it's true my parents
before they got married my dad's last
name was Cummings and my mom was coming
with no ass so I couldn't even like take
my mom's name or something when they got
divorced right they had the same name
yes with my mom was coming Cummings her
maiden name is coming with no ass I know
no relation obvious none I mean I don't
know Virginia in Texas it's anyone's
girl that's fuckin what it's not wild I
want to do my ancestory thing but nobody
will let me I bet you want to do that
huh no you're too worried about them
making like a taking your data oh yeah I
just I I am astounded by the complete
lack of privacy now and how corporations
just gobble up all of this fucking
information and how the government who
tries to do that themselves doesn't have
a problem with people these companies
that have now grown bigger than this
country and have no loyalty loyalty to
us and keep us in never-ending Wars and
bankrupt the country and all of this
shit that if you talk about it they just
say you're a socialist now I kind of
like living here and I wouldn't I don't
want six people to get all the money I'm
so fucking torn about it though because
they found that Golden State killer from
one of those ancestry tests because of
any of your ancestors take it
he's like cousin yeah did it
it's a great time it's a good argument I
mean I don't know I just fight but I
don't think that that's why they did it
no I think not at all cops yeah did a
good thing with it I don't think the
company though right
necessarily I think they're just trying
to make fucking money and they're just
taking your stuff and you know those
little scan you a little gear a little
discount card yeah you know it's just
like shouldn't I get a cut on my
information too should get a piece of
that nope no they're selling it to
insurance companies and then your
insurance goes up I was reading about
this thing how Google basically now can
predict if you're gonna have Parkinsons
the way your mouse is moving if your
mouth starts moving slower and if you're
older and they sell that to your
insurance company yeah and here's the
thing how do you even know that's true
yes is the thing that sounds like a scam
that it's so they'll just make up this
bullshit stat right that's right hey
you're 90 I guess yeah I guess you were
right hey can I have my extra some of my
extra premium money back can I be good
no you know we got to put that through
the red tape he's fucking 90 he'll be
dead in two weeks we'll just send this
thing around and around around no I
think it's all yeah it's gross hey this
is getting depressing that's why I stay
away from you know I you know it's just
there's a lot of like shit that is
coming to fruition right now real fast
the fact that we're still debating it I
know you got to meet my robot you were
less creeped out than I thought you
would be most people are cool they get
real freaked out by it and upset you
were just kind of like all right there
it is now he's relieved that it didn't
look real at all it looks more real on
camera to you whoa no it's just sort of
looked and they fucking winked that was
that's what I had the video I saw but
now that it's just been fucking sitting
there like a couch potato in the wrong
face just looks like a corpse it doesn't
yeah it doesn't not no point I mean I
think if I walked into the house and
from behind you somebody put that in
there I'd be like what the fuck I would
think the chick from the ring was in
there because I do think that's the
thing because I loved in your special
what you were talking about with the
robots but now that I've been in the
trenches with them so much and I've seen
them I'm like they
look like shitty scarecrows like there's
nothing to be afraid of no but that's
the beginning that's right oh yeah darn
better yeah not in our lifetime
hopefully I can see where you shut my
special off halfway through that joke
I fuckin see I love that special so much
and I I just thought that was it's just
I mean you're I don't know I don't want
to give you compliments and for the fuck
out of you someone I have a lot of
questions that people wanted to ask you
a lot of people I want to know how's
your French coming along um it's not
coming along I can actually read it
pretty good yeah but as far as speaking
it I just haven't had a just I don't
there's nobody to speak it with but uh
I'm okay with it but I've kind of been
trying to do something else with my
personal time so I've you know being a
dad and stuff so stuff had to like kind
of be dialed down yeah I learned from
like listening so I'll like listen to
those like tapes like I used to know
French pretty well and I totally fucking
forgot it and if I listened to the tape
sometimes I can like you know like mimic
it picking up a language if you actually
go to the country and try to do it yeah
yeah it you need like 90 days and you
could functionally yeah I've maybe at 90
days but I mean you cuke within six
months you could functionally get around
yeah and like have phrases no mean not
you just memorized and then you just if
you were immersed in it like it's just I
think they won't let you like when I try
to speak French in another country
they're just like well let me just speak
English no fuck that I have to listen to
your bad English the fact that French
people act like they speak English well
the fuck up I want to see me you fucking
little puckered up lips you're gonna
listen to my fucking wide mouth English
French and I'll listen to your puckered
up funny and they're like I'll take it
from here and then they have some shitty
ass English so I'm just like why are we
doing this I got me ah your English is
terrible just terrible I do think your
English is better than my fucking French
French I mean it is but I mean it's just
this there's a then I I mean I've
actually found when I've gone there that
if you're making a fucking attempt like
they've they spoke spoke it back to me
like this yeah then while I got it up to
like a three back and forth exchange at
one point before they like wow
and they switch over to English I do
find though the masculine and feminine
it makes you realize how much easier
English is that's always when I'm gonna
say I'm gonna go English is just easier
you know because you don't have to have
two versions of every word like the
masculine version and the feminine
version I also get embarrassed I need to
work on getting embarrassed less when I
try to say someone else's language
really it's just embarrassing
you have to like be vulnerable or
something I mean surprise feminists
haven't had a problem with the French
language it's like what's this gender
there's why is la maison why is the
house feminine is this a meanness that's
if I can stay her nagging cook for you I
don't like it when people imply that
women should be in the kitchen the
richest women are the ones that have
cooking shows oh is that right
Rachael Ray Martha Stewart Oprah all she
offers not in the kitchen she does her
on her Instagram now she has her harvest
and she cooks and her vet like her
gardener come in there she has her
harvest when you're that rich I love
harvest day you could go back to
pretending to be pulled did she ever
Ralph Lauren I'm gonna go gardening
outfit on thousand dollar fucking Sun
Hat you have to get these I love these
you're getting a hat you're getting a
hat the whole thing is so fucking read
it that the Oprah like the gifting
things where they call Oprah's Favorite
Things it was all like a 200 dollar
candle but yes and she was making all
this fucking money off of it Oprah's
Favorite Things how else can i carve up
what I've built to make even more
fucking money I can't believe people
fucking sit and watch that shit nothing
against her just bringing her up but
there's some of that shit was just like
how much should this fucking going up
your own asshole can you fucking watch
here but don't you think there's a
certain point where people are
surrounded by so many yes people that
they probably just have lost touch with
reality and what no I think I can just
be fucking just be like alright let's
it's like I don't know that band kiss
mm-hmm alright let's have a lunch box
and I get so let's have a fucking urinal
cake and a coffin fly swatters I mean
you know a little perforated fucking the
the kiss fly fucking thing it after a
while you just I think it just takes on
a life of its own you just get sick of
say no so you're like fine just anything
with alliteration they'll make kiss
curtains birds I like that I like that
yet they haven't made kiss lip balm for
some reason the one thing I might buy I
do though think that that I I don't know
I got in trouble a little bit on my
special about this but I do like to like
point out the hypocrisy in all this shit
where it's just like people like women
aren't supposed to be in the kitchen
it's like what what Rachael Ray has a
castle in Italy is that not feminist she
really yeah she's a castle from cooking
in the kitchen every morning on her show
I just think that there's this thing
where it's like she makes what I make
20-minute meals I just watch it all the
time
I called that by the way a long time ago
did she be rich I was like there's some
about her and this chick I was dating at
the time was just going like hey she's
such a dumpy da whatever the fuck that
means I think she's kind of fucking hot
yes she is there's something I like
about her though was she went a little
too far into the business they
highlighted her hair and all that type
of shit and then she dialed it back and
got back to who she was she you saw the
whole fucking arc huh
that's interesting I've done her show a
couple times have you done hurts show
before there's no fucking way I would
ever go in one of those ships there's
nobody who watches those shows that
needs to hear anything that I say like
you got to know who the fuck you are and
that's one of those dumb things where if
somebody I know who was like me went on
one of those shows and got in trouble
yeah I'd be like what the fuck were you
doing on that show for you're gonna talk
conspiracy and fucking banging whores
Steve on a fucking cooking show that
comes on at 4:00 in the afternoon what
did you what did you think was gonna
happen it is weird because any time I do
one of those shows and they're like here
now you're gonna be tasting food and
you're like okay and like there's no
version you can just like it's fine like
you have to make delicious it's like
it's also fakey fake and weird but just
watch you did it I did it many times did
it well then you can't complain about it
literally I didn't like the toast the
first time right I'll fucking come back
for the eggs I feel like I have to do
all that shit but when you go on a talk
show it becomes like a thing every when
you go on a talk show people like start
sending it around it's a for better or
for those delights to watch you go on to
a morning show well you know what I got
I got a
that was a being an old-timer here when
I was growing up a comedian being able
to do panel was a big thing they do and
there was like certain guys that I would
watch that were fucking great at it and
there was other people that would watch
to stand up and then they would sit down
and they weren't as good and and Plus
back then like how long you had to be in
the business how many people you had to
beat out just to get on there like they
everybody was was polished like I'm at
George Gobel was I was a big fan of his
still am a big fan of his but he was
considered like not at the level of you
know like like but he was he mean
competing there's that famous one we was
on with like Dean Martin and Bob Hope
and all those guys but he still like to
this day like would be like compared to
most people that get on cuz you can get
on so easily now easier cuz everybody
has like a fucking show or you tell men
that they're just not as seasoned as
this guy was with this whole background
and there was just so many people out
there that like it was I don't know
whose it was very rare that if somebody
was in show business and they sat down
on the couch that they didn't have a
good panel yeah it was obviously if a
fucking lion tamer comes in somebody
who's like you know would've been show
business or some weirdo then it became
about the host reacting to them but I
that was just something I always wanted
to get good at so I appreciate that
compliment it's so and I don't show
sometimes because you go on and was like
oh let's see if we can get through this
without getting an FCC violation like
everyone likes shame really I'm a
comedian like I'll try to behave myself
they sell they just selling it yeah they
do they just sell like they're just
selling the fucking show that you just
you got a block all of that out and you
just go out and you do what you do and
then you just stay off social media for
three days whenever those group of
people were that didn't like you which
is not a story now it's like oh my god
everybody didn't like it everybody
doesn't fucking like ice cream some
people actually don't like ice cream you
can believe that you could actually find
a group of people I can say I don't like
ice cream
I don't understand those people but like
you you can you know if you just put the
camera on them you've had a major
backlash against ice cream I think use
your headaches rot your teeth it's that
time of year again and you know it's
time to share smiles and a good times
with friends and family yeah and it
comes of course the sound exchange gifts
how about you give yourself a goddamn
gift am I allowed to curse in these
probably not the gift of self-confidence
what better gift is that how do you get
self-confidence by having straighter
brighter teeth with help from candid
candids aligners can help you straighten
your teeth faster and cheaper than
traditional wire braces which are a
living nightmare a haddem didn't go well
for me treatment of candid takes just
six months on average and cost 65% less
well where do you want people an
experienced orthodontist who is licensed
in your state creates custom treatment
plans they show you a 3d preview so that
you can see what your teeth will look
like after you're done that's incredible
it's like Star Wars for your face
candids aligners are comfortable
removable and completely invisible give
yourself the gift of candid go to candid
co.com / Whitney use the code Whitney to
get seventy five dollars off that's a
lot of money off and candid code calm /
Whitney code Whitney for seventy five
dollars off don't make me say it again
and you know I will
Canada TOCOM slash Whitney code Whitney
write it down pull over I do like to
kind of fight with people in the
comments though I hate that I do but I
do you know what I always do I make you
what you really got to do is you go
after their picture it's always someone
who come to me and be like you dumb
can't you look old and it's all good guy
and his daughter and I always say I feel
sorry for your daughter I'm sorry that
you're her father then immediately
changes the photo when this guy goes I
can't member he said to me aren't you a
little bit old to blah blah blah and I
go I
a little bit old to be taking selfies on
a bridge I don't know what that means he
had just taken a selfie on a bridge and
it just shut the whole fucking thing
down that's what you do you just go
after their picture but the people who
say the mean is shit I do not have a
fucking picture they're like a BOTS like
well that's like people I think that
make profile fake one's just a troll
right is that what that is yeah which I
respect if you're doing it to just get a
rise out of somebody I think that's
fucking hilarious yeah even if you get
me I think it's fucking funny but if
you're doing it because you're too much
of like a coward to like use like your
real account and but you're saying shit
you actually mean that's because a troll
I don't think he's saying they don't
mean it they're just trying to get
attention yeah I would have done that
like back in the day when I was growing
up if I could have fucking type
something and sent it to somebody on TV
I mean how long do you do that before
you like let me see if I can fucking
make him mad I mean it was like when you
bought a BB gun when I was a kid first
you know you shooting the trees and then
if looking some cans and eventually
you're gonna shoot at each other you
just have to keep I know it's kind of
how humans bark yeah I got a progress
look at you the I would have done that
and I got to tell you as far as like
being like an angry person and dealt
with anger for a long time which is
weird I really learned that I'm not an
angry person it's my default emotion and
trying to separate that has been my kind
of my life's work here but like if you
can if you can go empathy as much as you
can yeah outside yourself and just be
you know you know it kind of did takes
down a lot of that stuff but if I'm in a
fucking mood it's why I don't like I
don't read I prime maybe read like eight
percent other comments yeah if I put
something out yeah and I want to see
what the general feedback is I just
scroll until I get to the bad one that's
why that's cool I had about twelve good
ones one bad one one hundred twenty to
ten and then I go everyone's saying this
I'm the one that blows it up and
amplifies it but that's really not the
metrics at all and social media has been
out for too long for you to still be
doing that so you're you just
gonna be doing like some sort of sell
I'm giving a man power you hear it's
cutting me like I want to go hurt myself
I'm gonna go seek out the thing that's
gonna you know justify what I'm already
thinking and make me feel like a victim
and get me into my dopamine adrenaline
what I do then you go eat a big bowl of
chocolate cereal in your backyard hit my
robot take my rage out on her feet your
dog I went to I went to the Twitter
offices and they said that in America
22% of people are on Twitter of that 2%
of people generate 80% of the copy I saw
something like that yeah of course yeah
Cory all knew that didn't we all know
that I think we all secretly kind of
knew that but didn't want to believe it
I was like are you sure convenient that
doesn't fit my narrative but I do though
sort of get even more annoyed when I
confront somebody and then they're like
oh I'm sorry I didn't think you'd see
this I was just fucking around I'm like
well now at least commit can't yeah
you're gonna bring a lot of that shit
you get a lot of shit yeah you get a lot
of shit yeah as as do a lot of
attractive women get shit either way
either fucking love the blah blah or
they just you just get fucking shit so
you have to know like how they're gonna
come at you like I know with me you
bald-headed pasty fucking mongoloid I
guess I didn't give a shit that they
said that about me it's one of the
funnier fucking I actually burst it out
laughing when I wrote the word up too
cuz someone's like that's not a bad word
but I guess it came it came from some
everything comes from no I do think
you're like technically not supposed to
it's what it's on the list of things
that you're not supposed to maybe say
come on you gotta keep some of those
we're mongoloid has to stick around well
what I love is all these you know all
these woke people who are using all the
latest terms like these terms are then
gonna be outdated oh no it's gonna be
offensive in two years I'm trying to
think of I said gender creative once cuz
that was the new thing and then they
said it's gender non-conforming and then
I was like okay and then it was gender
non-binary what is it
Benson can tell us Jenna fluid yeah
gender fluid or queer okay but that's
not the same thing is it gender fluid
means you're bisexual
that queer means no gender fluid is mean
some days you feel more like a boy and
some days you feel more like a girl all
right and this is thing now am I in
trouble because I didn't know that too
busy trying if I fucking put a bed in
who's gonna win the Super Bowl
alright that's that's what the stats I'm
focused on right yeah who's gonna win I
think the Seattle Seahawks are gonna go
up against the Baltimore Ravens yeah and
I think I think Pete Carroll is gonna
get a second ring that's what I think
I'm so I'm from DC and I feel like you
can't even say the name of my team
anymore
the bullets no DC Washington the team
from Washington is what they say now
don't they instead of Redskins Redskins
yeah I went on Rich Eisen show and I was
like I'm a Washington Redskins fan and
he was like they say the team from
Washington since when I think recent
yeah but I gotta be honest with you that
is one that I don't know how the fuck
that one like I don't all this shit that
they're fucking changing that one is
just sitting there they sure didn't know
what we were talking about here's one of
those people on the side of our helmets
Native Americans none of that color the
skin is not red Redskins ever in washing
I'm more Redskin fucking Washington
gingers do you think they should change
the Redskins name ah that's one of those
ones there's certain things like that
doing that stupid Tomahawk Chop it's
just like oh my god how the fuck are you
still doing that I mean I went to
tomahawk just bunch of white people just
like you look like you were in a fucking
Western in the 1930s I'm waiting for
like a black and white John Wayne to
come walking on or I gotta go up the
fuck and whatever the fuck that guy used
to see just like some high schools that
still say engines go engines I look this
up I got real into it yeah but you know
something I bet they also live in the
middle of nowhere they don't get the
good food right I don't get the good
books yeah very easy to be sitting out
here with your fucking almond milk no
and what to say
that's right now you live in the middle
of nowhere with a rusted-out Derek
behind you
hey come on and then empathy see you
gotta see forgiveness that's my new
thing I was talking to my therapist
about people that were leaving nasty
comments and I read them to her and she
went god it sounds like they're in a lot
of pain I was like when you went off
I do have rage I don't I'm actually Pro
rage because I grew up in a home where
everything was bottled and everything
was passive-aggressive and there was a
lot of direct communication people were
like no I'm fine everything's fine
no I'm not mad go do that like I I like
when people are angry because I at least
know it's honest communication I like
I'd like to know why stand you got a
long road ahead of you you probably
catch up with me but I'm walking down
that same Road I feel bad do you feel
bad for you regularly I know I know
where you're at right now I'm justifying
rage justify rage
you're trying least you know I yeah you
know I Maggie I tell it like it is it's
it no you're it's able you're able to oh
you're in therapy that's a good fucking
thing oh yeah I did find out what
therapy is is if you're just going in
there and emptying your brain every week
but you're not actually working on it
it's like it would be like sitting down
and talking about working working out
you're never going to the gym no I'm
like 12-step program I like do the whole
deal you know doing the whole thing it's
like exercise go to it every day you
release your resentments every night I
write out who I'm mad at and who I'm
holding resentment towards on my little
app how's it working it's you know it's
going pretty fucking wound tight at the
fucking store we know yeah I would not
make you mad it I got a tree delivered I
get real mad about like little things
big things I don't even care car wrecks
like I'll leave my car and I'm like I'll
deal exactly how I am we should by the
way that was kind of a weird moment bill
just came over and we just watched
coyotes walk around in my yard yeah
there was a wall but is it that's why
that's why I keep telling
my wife when my daughter goes outside
it's like this coyotes out here porch in
Arizona a baby oh my god why did I bring
that up I just ruined my fucking day how
do you ever get past that I don't and
you're telling me if there's a God and
he lets that happen and then you blow
your brains out because you can't deal
with that fucking sadness which is
exactly what the fuck I would do he's
then gonna give me shit for fucking
killing myself this is why I go this is
why I don't go to church it doesn't
fucking make sense this is why I get so
angry shit like that he we just showed
videos I wake up in the middle of the
night sleepwalk and fight with coyotes
in my sleep because I'm so afraid of I'm
taking my dogs after I heard that story
fucked up my whole life
shouldn't brought it up sorry who would
have thought your robot is less fucking
scarier Jesus Christ you fucking sleep
you know fucking i sleepwalk yeah do you
sleep well some nights I do yeah I think
III as I've gotten older and and you
know found a person I'm supposed to be
with and now I have a beautiful daughter
it's like this there's ramifications for
my action so I really have to you know I
get a fucking chill so I play drums a
lot I do that a lot like I try to do
that when that's sort of my little thing
I'll just say I'm gonna go out in the
garage and see if my drums still work
that's what I say
and then does it you'd be a great
drummer I mean it would be good for you
it's fun really it's yeah it's a low
yeah oh yeah I had an injury I broke my
shoulder and I can't box which was the
thing that I really like to get
aggression out I can't do that anymore
but drumming maybe I'll try I suck at
I'm sure I suck at it though well I mean
you suck at everything when you start it
but you just keep building it up and now
with like YouTube and shit that's sort
of limitless as far as like what you can
see out there like the kids that play
drums now or fucking their fucking
unbelief unbelievable
young no right no it's because then now
you basically jamming with the world
like it was like when you grew up when I
was a kid you were as good as what you
could take from a record and who was in
your neighborhood to show you shit yeah
so that was your world was very small
and like nowadays it's just like
everything that was a mystery to me
growing up as far as far as my the music
I was listening to has been broken down
the music literally broke out written
out so then like that the ideas that
then get created it doesn't but the only
thing it has done is it makes a lot of
people sound the same where there used
to be like a this is this Philly
drummers sound like this yeah you know
Boston guys sound like this Detroit had
a sound like cities had sounds and I
think that that gets that gets hurt now
it's just sort of all becoming like like
like one uniform sort of sound girl was
on a couple other sets ago and I
rewatched that sonic highways did you
ever see that techno and watch
everything that gets so good yeah I love
that so much
you seem like you watch Lodge
documentaries for a minute um yeah I do
you know some of them I get into some of
them not really I I watch a lot of old
shit and then I watch I watch a lot of
sports
I think but and then I'm totally into
like music and shit like that in fucking
aviation and baking like a zillion fuck
it's like my 80 I just fuckin I gotta be
doing something and learning something
but comedies the only thing I ever
really stuck with so I was the only
thing I ever really kind of got good at
everything else I kind of you know jack
of all trades but I actually you know
one of the best live drummers ever saw
was Dave I saw Dave Grohl on the DEM
crooked vultures tour so I'm at The
Wiltern and it was really cool cuz I
also got to see one of the members of
Led Zeppelin because John Paul Jones was
in that course Josh Homme II and I
forget who the guy who they had a hired
gun on guitar was fuckin killer and it
was just like it was I was awesome was
just they were just everybody in that
band was just the real deal and they
came out and the hell was the song there
was some song that in the end it's just
as this Phil that Dave Grohl does it
was so fucking clean but still was also
like had like human element it wasn't
like it just was fucking so I was just
like when he was playing I couldn't
believe it and then the person I was
with who didn't even play drums I was
like Jesus Christ that guy's that guy's
like really good cuz they're not like
drummers don't get a lot of love now
I've got of people know Dave Grohl
because he's a from in a Foo Fighters
but like if you were just like the
drummer in the band there's a lot of
people you know everybody knows Jim
Morrison they don't know they don't know
John Densmore you know I mean so it
doesn't the drummer kind of set the
there in a way the conductor in a way
like they sort of set the beat from what
I've heard I mean yeah I I don't do that
if I play with people but like great
drummers yes it's basically like the
heartbeat of the band well basically if
you like a good it's almost like an
editor in a movie that's where like an
editor can take a good performance and
make it great or take a good performance
and make it bad I feel like a drummer
does the same thing which they can take
a good band and and can elevate a sound
like or you can just drag them down
mm-hmm you know like the unsung hero
also a little bit yeah probably I mean
I'm I mean I don't know shit about it
but I guess as far as like is being an
admirer of drummers I just always
thought it was the coolest fucking
instrument with like the independence
and then also just having a sports
background the physical aspect I always
I always liked it but this yeah there's
some monster monster monster plays out
there I actually you know what I just
came across was Mars Volta had an EP
that they put out but I had never even
heard of I only listened to their first
three albums I just discovered it and
I'm a huge Jon Theodore fan and the last
song on that is there's a drum groove
that he plays it's just it's just it's
fucking mind-boggling is it like kind of
like how quarterbacks they say are like
Surrey is is drumming it is it's pretty
cerebral isn't it as well as physical
like I said I don't know I mean it's
just a hobby for me I even I don't I
don't know but I I think from what all
the interviews that I've watched the
Malayan but like there's like I actually
saw one thing on Vinnie Colaiuta one
time
who's our birthing arguably the greatest
fucking drummer alive right now he was
talking about someone was asking him
about a drum fill this crazy fucking
drum fill that he did that he just it
somehow fit and they were like these
things that you work on is like you know
I work on stuff whatever and then are
you thinking tonight I'm gonna pull that
that fill out and he said no he said I I
just let it go
I don't think about it and he said and
he said this most such a profound thing
that transcended drumming he said
thinking is the enemy so it's not like
you're out there like County it's like
you're more like listening whatever and
like you know as a comedian where are
you when you're the worst when you're
between your ears and now I'm doing this
joke totally so that's gonna be a mean
by the way you're doing this the walrus
but then there's Knights like one of the
best things that can ever happen is you
walk out immediately and you get heckled
I find that Richard Pryor special if you
watch that down in Long Beach that's how
he walked out people weren't sitting
down they were talking and he just
started flowing and he got into a
fucking zone like I've never seen since
and he got into this fucking zone from
the beginning to the specials like an
hour and 18 minutes or something like
that 14 minutes I forget
it just is just chilling yep killing and
that was like he had that set that that
never happens on the special night ever
you know I mean you're so he fucking had
that like set and and I've you know just
being a fan of music I've listened to
musicians and it's it's sort of it's
dead that same thing like when you're in
the zone the same thing like when you
know basketball players can't miss a
shot there's a thing that you get into
like is you know as a comedian you just
get out there and you improv and it's
funny and it's just you just feel like
you light you're just floating and then
the very next show is always the worst
cuz the next show is like is it gonna
happen again to replicate what you're
thinking about the last show so then you
hear and you're just going like and then
I said this and then I did this improv
enough
working and you like oh I thought I had
20 minutes of new stuff I don't even
have 30 seconds and I think they call it
flow State there was a there was an
interesting book about flow State but
then if you're trying so hard to a
terrible name such a beautiful thing to
experience flow State chop-chop sounds
like a like a like always with wings
like easy flow day it sounds like a
woman's sanitary pad it's just for
something that it's describing mm-hmm
it's a flow State it's the exact
opposite signs like when you're fucking
stuck in your head when you're not
thinking about what you're doing so many
times I feel like in specials like
you're looking down on yourself like
just doing the thing you've been doing
get out of there get in there so you
have to develop I just sort of developed
like tricks to get myself out of that oh
so well it what it is is what you don't
realize is every night you fuck up a
joke
you fucked something up every even you
don't like it I'm gonna set you fucked
something up right we had like a brain
fart something fucking happen but you
don't notice cuz it's not being
documented and it's then with a second
the camera comes on it becomes like oh
my god and everybody's gonna know and
it's just I you have to get yourself
into that like I just look at a special
is like this is like this is not going
to be the perfect performance you're
just documentary where my act was on
this night right here and I'm gonna come
out with the same yeah it's a weird
thing because the stakes aren't where
they are but you really you have to put
them back down to some to a functioning
level so you can just go out and do what
you do and it takes it takes a number of
those to learn how to do that it's so
hot usually what I try to do is I'll try
to get it and then go okay we got it now
the next one's the one and then I also I
was talking to my firt elite about this
who runs Phil's company he's just the
greatest
I was like I want to just do 10 shows
and you guys just secretly record one of
them just don't tell me what I've
thought about that or if I recorded 10
yeah but then what you're doing is then
then you're making like you know I feel
like that's the comedy version of when
they over produce an album yeah and then
there's no mistakes
there's nobody breathing on it yes just
it's just like everything's like you
know been Pro tool than just
and lined up I mean I feel like the
stuff that people the same way like the
stuff that people like the most are the
mistakes that's right oh it actually
makes it like you know it's like when
you know if you ever done like a sitcom
taping ever the crowd goes if you fuck
up a line yes that's what they came
that's right berserk they don't and they
don't want to see a prepackaged polished
thing people are also so savvy now
someone was telling me that photos get
twice as many likes if your arm is in it
and you're taking it yourself but if you
do like perfectly like Wes Anderson
symmetrical good photo in front of the
leaning tower we've seen it no thanks -
perfect
really mm-hmm not interesting yeah we're
moving towards like we want authentic we
want messy we want sort of not sloppy I
don't know if we want authentic I know
people say they're like no watch
authentic would also be the truth of
everything which I don't think anybody
could handle why I'm fucking watching me
TV me TV there's a couple questions
people have for you you ask so many that
I was reluctant one thing I did want to
ask you about was the Surf ballroom
Clear Lake Iowa show oh wow it was
amazing yeah a lot of people wanted to
hear your thoughts on it I don't know
anything about it all right that's the
place where Buddy Holly Ritchie Valens
and the Big Bopper performed and then
they died they got on a plane I don't
think it was well deicing i don't know
if that existed back then I don't know
what it was or the kid was too
inexperienced 40 flew into and they they
died but I always just wanted just being
a music fan I wanted to see the place
and I went on the road with with who was
I with I was with Dean Del Rey and I was
in this regular hotel and then Dean
found just randomly in that town who's
good with architects I'm really bad
who's that fucking Carrie I'm good with
it that guy who built everything out
they built like slam but they almost
look like fucking King Tut looking
houses can we Google King Tut I always
want to they always want to say like
fucking l ron Hubbard
I know he has some good built it so it's
one of those fucking energy buildings
always very they have great taste and
real estate those Scientologists yeah
they do and Frank Lloyd Wright oh well
yeah ron Hubbard Oh got it
right there was a Frank Lloyd Wright
hotel in the middle of for guy oh yeah
and it was this shit so we stayed there
that's wild we flew we flew into like
Detroit or something I don't forget
where we flew maybe Chicago something
like that yeah and then we took like
this little plane there yeah
so of course everything oh my god we're
taking a little plane are we gonna die
it's like no they have technologies it's
all kind I think the pilots have kids
the pilots want to stay alive itis on
them and it was also a woman pilot knew
we could like see her and it was sitting
there like it was like nothing in my
body and I was a different flight my
body was I had another buddy that
freaked out was just like it should be a
woman when women should not be fucking
pilot sounds like dude they gone through
probably went to extra bull I'm saying
they have to be twice as good I hope yes
but with all this bitching on social
media they might have been pressured
into a higher which I've seen in sports
I see they'll push someone into the
broadcast booth before they fucking
ready to be like say hey we have a
vagina about female president the worst
thing that could happen is someone
that's not ready does it they go see
this is why we shouldn't have a female
president this is why we shouldn't it's
just gonna actually make the stereotype
true if you push someone in before
they're ready yeah I don't let the
Democrat trend - of like after the guys
president then the wife runs like I
don't understand that one at all because
it's the thing of it's like I've dated a
couple guys that decided to become
comedians after we dated and like did I
make it seem so easy that look easy you
you didn't see me for eight days at a
time I cry every Sunday and you see me
just like why just like that there's
women career politicians who have the
experience but then someone who is
rubbing elbows they're like I saw
someone do it yeah same thing I just do
a bit on that should Tom Brady's wife be
the next quarterback of the Rams cuz
they left some playbooks around no but
this is new pressure that like that a
first lady is actually a job
and that they have the weight of the
world and sake you don't how about
whatever was like why does it Oprah run
for president no that is the worst I'm
not gonna name any names but if through
celebrities have thrown their fuckin hat
in the ring it's just like dude do you
understand that do you see how these
people age know what that is that's not
the economy that's the dead bodies
that's the dead babies that the drone
hit you don't you yeah you don't shake
that off this isn't just an Christmas
trees yeah the holidays how much high of
a fucking Fame buzz are you looking for
here that you want to stick you and
you're making some stupid fucking movie
or a bunch of people die but they don't
die and now you want to fucking actually
do that for real you want to do that you
want to fucking go we want to have your
finger on the nuke button that's what
yeah you're out of your fucking mind do
the parades you want to get on the
helicopter they think that it's like the
king and the Queen we don't have a king
a queen
we have a president that actually is
responsible for real shit I think that I
think that with all the like King and
the Kate Middleton and print well I
think we cannot run it I look at them
like you know like when I used to do
with a thing on this where like when
your flight gets canceled yeah and
everybody yells at the person tear in
the tickets and they're like I never
flying your airline again it's like my
airline like that person is literally
there to tear tickets and then get
yelled at when shit goes wrong that is
their fucking or it's least part of the
job that's what the president that's
that's a smile and wave and get blamed
for fucking everything and there's
people yeah like that he makes he makes
like fucking for 2 grand a year kids
writing songs on YouTube make more
fucking money than the President of the
United States so true you don't think he
has to fucking answer to somebody pilot
female pilot going oh yeah oh yeah so we
flew it was fucking great yeah it's
awesome and I know geeking out looking
at all the different things that they
have to do because it's a little totally
different it's the same principles but
completely different and helicopters
yeah
well we can kind of stop in the air and
if they stopped they'd be just fucking
dead guys they have like the whole glide
slope and the three degrees and all this
shit that they have to fucking line up
yeah and I am but I mean yeah I mean
yeah it's uh but the show is not for the
faint of heart
no we went
and it's in like they have not changed
it ever since they had it so it's like
stepping back in time
they changed the green room a little bit
but they had like they literally have
like it locked they had the phone booth
where it's kind of more of it would
Buddy Holly on the phone called his wife
for the last time and it was yeah it was
you know I don't know I I kind of ran
out of stadiums to go to so now I'm kind
of on this music thing where I just try
to go to like like I'm doing this this
venue in Memphis coming up and I'm a
huge Stevie Ray Vaughan Double Trouble
fan and Tommy Shannon Chris Layton Reese
whinings I fucking love that band and I
saw this this clip of them a new clip
kind of came up with some live stuff
that in Memphis I'd never seen and I was
like wow where they playing in Memphis
it was like oh the Orpheum I and they
they did redo it one time because I get
really into that whole walking on the
same if they redid it I don't give a
fuck but if you're walking on the same
boards you feel like that magic of that
energy is somehow in there and like my
last stand-up thing I did like I my
favorite concert footage of Led Zeppelin
and John banas with my favorite drummers
yeah was in Royal Albert Hall and like
that was the big thing to get pushed
through where I was like this is where
Robert Plant's to it and John Bonham's
drums were right fucking I couldn't
believe it I couldn't finish and it
still that kind of looks the same so
that's cool yeah it was like yeah it
gave me the chills is that recent is it
is it sort of like you know as a
stand-up it's you're like okay I'm
selling out theatres I'm selling out
stadiums you know I'm bill now
Kevin Hartz tells out stadiums I'm
theatres MSG is not a game
the forum is a you know arenas wound and
then it becomes about like okay the
thrill is now that you can process all
that or have gone through it now it's
like okay I get to be in the presence of
greatness well I you try to still be a
fan and then you still try to improve
and then you block out all compliments
and criticism except for the your you
know the people that you trust yeah you
know something's going on you know
you're kind of doing this to my
I will you know that somebody I respect
I listen to but I'm not gonna listen to
you know some random person on social
media you have your go-to people they're
like yeah telling me that a joke isn't
funny or like because yeah what the fuck
do you know me what do you do for a
living mm-hmm you fucking build cars I'm
gonna tell you you put the transmission
in the wrong way what the fuck do I know
about it you know you do what you do I
do what I do you don't have to like it
I have a friend that I've known forever
from Boston and he knew me before I did
stand-up and he's the person I go to to
run things by anything and I show him
specials I show him everything because I
know he'll always tell me the truth like
do you have that person in your life is
it Nia yeah yeah it is when she finally
gives it up that's a wife's job they got
a fucking keep yeah you trust her
judgment yeah and most stuff and in this
stuff I'm just like now you don't get it
you don't get it that's funny yeah I
believe it I know I know what I'm doing
with this and I'm gonna get there like I
had a bit my act that I'm doing right
now that the first time I did it like
two women started screaming at me and I
told me go fuck themselves and then he
waited for me afterwards it was a big
fuck you fuck you thing and you know I
cooled off like three days later and I
was like that's not what I want to be
doing when I'm up there so I was like I
need to figure out how to say what I'm
saying so people hear it and I'm doing
that none of that bit gets like the best
and I feel really positive it might turn
into like yeah this more like you know
when I really got down to what the fuck
I was trying to say right but you're
chiseling at the marble no that's why
people shouldn't like film comics and
stuff and then just post it up there I
mean if people do that then you can't be
like I said this is it so work I'm
fucking working on this shit yeah it's
not done yet I didn't say it was done
yeah this is where there's no way to
safely work out do you do the Yonder
bags to put people's phones in it shows
I haven't but I maybe I will
it all depends yeah like it's it's
upsetting when people do that I don't
think people do it
Ashley yeah I think they're actually
doing it because they're a family they
don't realize how they're ruining all
the surprise endings to all your ideas
that's right it's not like because I
would think a lot of them go to see
bands and bands are cool yeah man get my
music out there
it's snitchy to me sometimes I think a
lot of people now I think after the
Louis thing with the the say and the
Chappell thing they kind everyone wants
to get the thing where a comic slips you
know like they want no yeah it's just
all I think we're already out of bounds
when we walk onstage that's what you're
going to sense right that's right now
we're gonna bust you going out of bounds
I know I don't think that exists yeah
much anymore
yeah they try to fucking think about how
offended people were okay about so much
fucking shit unless me and where is that
now outrage yeah it's a drug rule
ephemeral it's just it's it's easily
turned over it's quick fast it's here
and then it's gone it's like people are
just she didn't ride horses
[Laughter]
yes I'd work fucking harder to try to go
to college I used to I remember I was
such a weirdo in high school and I hated
when people say that I hate it when
people are like I was a nerd in high
school but I was just like I was just
like a weird like loner I'm just like
loner II and I used to read the
dictionary and memorize try to memorize
words because I didn't have an SAT tutor
so I I would like memorize words for
that oh so you had to get you had to
take the initiative yeah I knew a woman
like that a long time ago no I'm gonna
say her name was
she was she danced on Broadway and I
wasn't I wasn't seen or anything yeah
but she liked her I remember the story
was like her mother was like I haven't
using or whatever yeah and she just got
herself out of it cuz she figured out
through other people what she needed to
do and she just come home but mom sign
this - sign that sinus and she got the
fuck out now I always I always admired
that I was like wow I wonder if I would
have had the wherewithal to do that and
I was like probably
not not for a while I don't think I
would it seem like she figured it out as
a kid when you come from alcoholic home
a lot of times you realize real quick
like I'm the adult here
I need a run shed oh you know I was
definitely doing I was like making
lunches making dinners and I was like I
know I'm not gonna get an SAT tutor all
the kids at school have a fucking tutor
I need to tutor myself I said to my
brain went through a really bad place it
was it one of those green room jokes I
could have just it's a green room joke I
blew the landlords to do all the adult
shit the fucking thing
are there any do you like meeting your
heroes or not just curious um mostly I
feel like you do now mostly they've been
cool the ones that I've met I think a
lot of people what I've learned is that
really successful people are fun to be
around
that's right like if you're a fucking
asshole you you can get there but you
won't stay there yeah like this there's
this thing out there that you know
that's interesting that theory that
feminist theory that guys you know women
have to be this way and guy could just
be a dick and everybody respects him
it's like now nobody wants to work for a
fucking asshole and when a fucking
asshole starts to fall nobody tries to
catch him yeah they let him all go down
and they enjoy every fucking branch they
hit on the way down and I've seen that
happen to plenty of fucking people so I
found that the I've yeah I've just found
him to be really like had a sense of
humor about themselves very humble yeah
and it had a little bit of a so and then
there's been you know but I find people
that aren't that good are the ones who
actually take the trip away take take
the run and always but I think they I
call taken the ride yeah and they just
kind of they get rid of their friends
and they surround themselves
III six joke with me Oyster Cult he's
got a case of the yeah yeah yes yeah
yeah
so true I've seen it happen to my
friends I mean I've seen it happen to a
couple people and I think that like
maybe there's some comics that are
getting like too famous off YouTube or
something too quick or something that
starts to happen there's an adjustment
period and then what if they come out
the other side then it's and then it's
fine I heard that I think was Bill
Maurice at one time used to give people
three years and he was like after three
years if you're still an asshole then
you're an asshole but like I thought
that was really empathetic genius oh my
god
you know everybody's blowing smoke he's
floating up we're gonna see if he comes
back down again three years lady still
up there half fuck that guy he also said
something on Howard Stern that I loved
about Fame he said you know Howard Stern
was like don't you love being famous and
he goes try being rich and see if you
still want to be famous
he says a lot of true pretty get that
he's like a lot of people want to be
famous but they actually just want to be
rich that make any sense yeah no I
totally do it's like a lot of people are
the comment be famous and you really you
don't want to be famous and poor but I
didn't I wanted to be famous I got in it
I wanted I wanted to be known as a
comedian yeah for sure me too I think
maybe I wanted to be and I want all the
people that I saw growing up I wanted
them to poke their head in and just say
I saw your act and you're funny it's all
I knew I didn't want to be like you know
and they were paddling around and blow
it the fucking Comedy Store I didn't
have any desire for that but I
definitely I've been the opposite with
money where it's like I want to have
enough yeah so I'm not on the fucking
Street but like I don't like freak out
about you know I could have gone across
the street and got that for 40 but I've
never been that way even when I was you
know coming up you know I never had that
hanging onto it other than when I first
moved to New York and I wasn't getting
any spots and I didn't have a fucking
day job and I'd built up a nest egg and
just watching that thing going down and
I was you know during my you know I was
never a ramen noodle guy I was just I
just ate pasta like every fucking night
just myself up with it what is what
would be what works on money for like
what my when you I have a very weird
early
share with money I'm it but what when
you spend money on something works like
yep that felt good I I like like if
there's something really of quality
mm-hmm I really wanted and I needed that
need and I need it
buying something really fucking cool for
somebody that I know is going to
appreciate it is is the is is is the
best thing ever because I don't want to
get too much into my personal life with
shit like that but there was someone in
my life that I I got him something and
like I got way more out of his fucking
reaction I love giving I'll show you the
video when I when I go to leaf we talked
about we've talked about money every
episode because I'm obsessed with money
because the first time I started making
any money that year I was like I'm rich
and then I couldn't afford my taxes I
know yeah I know and I had to do 80
cities I did 80 colleges in one year to
get money back because I had no idea how
money worked I knew you give half away
you give more half I mean taxes and
commissions and travel I always look at
30 if you get if you make $100,000
you're lucky if you get to keep 30
you're lucky very lucky if you get to
keep 30 because it's just you know it's
a it's a broken system that's right and
the people up top of chewing and
screwing and they leave the check - ever
has fucking money and doesn't have
high-powered lawyers he's fuck you just
got to pay Elvis taxes that's right
that's right and then there's a lot of
fake industry standards where you got to
pay a bunch people and the public and
all the shit and and so I couldn't so I
always talk about just like saving money
the more money I have the more I save it
and the people with the most money that
I know are the cheapest people on the
planet and I don't really save money no
I just make it and then but I don't buy
a lot of shit but I don't consciously
like fucking safe you have like a
retirement or like a 401k no I have that
yeah I have that but I have it on the
crap table yeah if I wish I could get it
off the fucking crap table which is the
fucking stock market yeah but I bought
in I'm in I'm in on the lie so I gotta I
gotta ride it out I think I'm gonna try
to invest in that company where you see
people
texting comics you've seen that when
people like text me oh that thing that
thing are you gonna do that
I try to stick with what I know yeah
asked me yesterday to invest in some
fucking thing make a fucking zillion
dollars you know you know your napkin
always fucking comes unfold this fucking
thing refolded for you okay we're over
time and I don't want to keep thank you
so much thank you this wasn't a total
hassle for you wasn't a hassle man I had
a good time okay I had a good time thank
you and good luck with working on your
anger I'm gonna do I'm still working on
mine f is for family the Mandalorian
Mandalorian holy shit I wore Mandalorian
when does that come out it's uh it's
streaming now right now I think the
fourth episode might have just dropped
but that's how much content is out there
that you're like Star Wars when is that
coming out well I hear about it a lot of
people texted me about it or asked me
questions about it but I felt bad asking
you about like all your projects oh I
didn't bring it up it's on Disney Plus
Disney Plus which I'm loving is apparent
because they got all the Disney cartoons
on babysitter and the old cartoons the
old animation is my favorite yeah we
were watching 101 Dalmatians last night
although I rewatched Bambi and that made
me sad I can't believe kids watch that
shit that's because Walt's fucking mom
died so now everybody has to go through
his that's like the thing like the
fucking lion Kings the same goddamn shit
why is it so sad I can't handle it
hierarchy i watch the good dinosaur on a
plane and I had to take a walk up and
down I couldn't that's that's their
thing they have to fucking rip your
kid's heart out so you'll stay to the
end of the movie I think that that's
what they do or it's a way to force your
kid to appreciate your parent your
parents alive stop yelling at him or
maybe Disney hates children this is a
two-part podcast everybody now it's
gonna get real like that stand-up
special that person did it was joke joke
jokes and then like now here's all the
pain behind it ah don't you I don't want
to know the truth behind this
don't do that to me it's a
bait-and-switch people can't handle that
counter-programming with the bank you
make a joke about your dead dog and this
is how my dog died candy from a child
I shouldn't have joked about I've done
I'm not fuckin shitting on the person
that did that I'm just just I don't know
fed into what the fuck I was just doing
you can tell please cut that out cut it
out we're gonna cut that out you don't
need any drama in your life cut it out
man you're like all right this is what
you come back on we just edit up
[Laughter]
[Music]